hey if you want to support more content
on this channel and also get some sweet
anime merge check out anime ah procom we
have original exclusive designs by pro
artist Cuusoo midi like this Eskin or
praise the sun shirt link in the
description
[Music]
what is up everybody at Santa Mack here
for anime uproar and I recently made a
video ranking the entire goddess clan
from weakest to strongest and of course
that means that I had to do a lot of
research on the goddess clan and on the
truth about the holy war that happened
three thousand years ago and one thing
really stood out to me about the actions
and ideology of the goddess clan a dark
secret an ugly truth that comes to light
more and more as the story develops
this secret not only makes the story
itself a lot more interesting and
complex than it appears at first glance
but it can actually teach us a lot more
about our own world which also has its
own dark secrets and ugly truths and
just like in the seven deadly sins these
truths may not be so obvious at first
glance but they can be discovered if we
look closely and of course if you like
this type of content and you want to see
more you can leave a like to let me know
if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification valve and if you want to
make video requests in the future or
just stay in touch with all the latest
updates here on the channel be sure to
follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar quick warning this video
will include manga spoilers the dark
truth about the goddess clan is only
becoming apparent now in the manga so
there is no way to avoid spoilers now
when i watched the first season of the
seven deadly sins anime and especially
those earlier episodes i honestly
thought that this series was going to be
just a light-hearted comedy some jokes
here some sexual innuendos there and a
lot of over-the-top magical battles i
thought that the story would be very
simplistic and the characters would be
your average good guys and bad guys and
in the end the good guys would win and
the bad guys would lose simple easy no
problem except at the end of season one
with the holy nights injecting
themselves with demon blood to become
stronger and some of the nights being
killed or turned into monsters because
of how their body reacted to the demon
blood i could tell that this series was
becoming more serious and more mature i
was intrigued and because there was no
season 2 at the time I decided to read
the manga because I
did not have the patience to wait I had
to see what happened next and as I read
the manga I started to see the story
developed from a lighthearted magical
comedy to something more complex and
more profound as we got the backstories
of the seven deadly sins as we learned
about the curses that were placed on
meliodas and Elizabeth and as we began
to learn the truth about the holy war
from 3,000 years ago the truth behind
the conflict between the demon clan and
the goddess clan I started to really
appreciate the quality of the writing
and the important lessons that this
fantastical story about Giants fairies
and demons has to teach us about the
real world our world when we are first
introduced to demons in the story we see
them destroying the fairy Kings forest
and killing Elaine we see their blood
being used to turn people into monsters
and we see the Ten Commandments
attacking humans and ruthlessly
consuming human souls as soon as they
are able to escape the coffin of eternal
darkness clearly at this point our
opinion of the demons is very negative
these are dangerous bloodthirsty
ruthless creatures that pose an
existential threat to humans and all
other beings around them and even though
we also find out that meliodas is
actually a member of the demon clan when
we learned that he betrayed the demons
in sided with the goddesses and other
races against the demon clan in the holy
war we tell ourselves that meliodas
is an exception he must have seen that
the demon clan was evil and dangerous
and that is why he turned against them
because he didn't want to be evil like
them the demons are the bad guys the
demons are villains
they are demons after all so how could
they be anything other than evil and on
the other hand when we learn about the
goddess clan these angelic divine
creatures remind us of heaven and light
and purity our first instinct is to
think that these are the good guys the
goddesses represent what is good true
and sacred and they are the ones
fighting against the evil and dangerous
demons I mean the goddess clan members
have beautiful white angel wings so what
else could they be except the good guys
it's simple easy
but the truth is it isn't simple at all
and this is what we learn as the story
goes on as we begin to really learn
about the holy war from 3,000 years ago
around chapter 203 of the manga we
realized that the goddess clan at least
the majority of the goddess clan is
actually extremely brutal and ruthless
even though they are allied with the
humans and other races against the
demons during the holy war the goddesses
don't actually care about their allies
the goddesses and the Archangel lunar
shell in particular are so obsessed with
exterminating the entire demon clan that
they don't differentiate between demons
who are innocent and haven't done
anything wrong and the demons who
actually attack and kill others the
goddesses simply want to kill every
single demon and of course if they did
succeed in exterminating the demons
their biggest rivals the goddess clan
would conveniently ensure that they are
by far the most powerful and dominant
out of all the clans most of the
goddesses are so extreme in their
beliefs that they are willing to take
innocent demons hostage to lure out the
ten commandments and then kill all the
hostages without remorse and if that
wasn't enough the goddess clan
mercilessly kills their own allies if
the allies get in the way of
exterminating the demons in the manga we
learn about a human named a troll whose
entire village was massacred by the
goddess clan because they were suspected
of helping a demon who had passed
through the village even though this
particular demon was kind and good and
didn't do anything bad to anyone just
for helping him the entire village
including women and children were all
slaughtered by the goddess clan in order
to teach the humans a lesson which is to
never help a demon under any
circumstances the treatment of humans by
the goddesses was so bad during the
previous holy war that role and other
humans were also victimized by the
goddess clan turned against them and
infiltrated stigma in order to kill as
many members of the goddess clan as
possible and even though that holy war
took place over 3,000 years ago it seems
clear that the goddess
and still has pretty much the same
worldview when it comes to both the
demons and other races such as the
humans the Archangel Ludo shell still
wants to exterminate all the demons
without mercy and he is willing to use
humans and their bodies such as the body
of Princess Margaret in order to achieve
his goals without caring about what
actually happens to the vessel itself
similarly when she was summoned by
Denzel the goddess niro basta
took possession of his body but instead
of showing any compassion for the humans
who summoned her she attempted to escape
and leave the humans who were there to
die one ability that higher ranked
goddesses can use is called the breath
of bless and this is also a fascinating
detail in the story breath of blessed
bestows extra strength onto a person of
the goddesses choosing but it also
brainwashes that person into becoming
fanatically loyal to the goddess clan to
the point that they would even sacrifice
their own lives just to do whatever the
goddess wants them to do
this ability breath of bless is the
perfect embodiment of the goddess clan
ideology they want to use humans and
other creatures as tools in their
crusade against the demons but they do
not value the wishes or the lives of
these creatures
it doesn't matter to the goddesses how
many humans or fairies or Giants died as
long as they achieve their own goals
which is the total annihilation of the
demons their biggest rivals what's more
as we've heard repeatedly from the
goddesses and Archangels like New
Rochelle and Miele the goddess clan
believes that the demons are filthy
impure creatures and that it is the
goddess clans duty to destroy them all
and not only that but most members of
the goddess clan believe that they are
actually doing the demons a favor by
killing them because according to the
goddesses it is more compassionate to
brutally murder a demon than to allow it
to continue living and while there are
members of the goddess clan who reject
this extremist approach including
Elizabeth and Jenna and Sunehri
we just need to look at what happened to
these three and it is easy to see how
the majority of the goddesses feel
Elizabeth was cursed by the supreme
deity her own mother for daring to fall
in love with a demon and Janna and
scenario
to possess human bodies in order to hide
from the goddess clan because their
decision to stop supporting the war
against the demons made them traitors
and targets for elimination
in the eyes of the goddesses this theme
of the self-righteous cruelty and
brutality of the goddess clan keeps
coming up again and again as the story
progresses but does this then mean that
all the demons are actually good if the
goddess clan are not really the good
guys then their enemies the demons must
be the good guys that would be the
simplest way to tell a story but as I
said before this story is not as simple
as it first appears it is actually
complex and nuanced just like real life
many of the demons are indeed cruel and
ruthless
we know that the demon king curses his
own son meliodas for disobeying him and
many demons do commit terrible acts
against other creatures including humans
killing them enslaving them and
devouring their souls but even so there
are good demons out there including of
course meliodas and the original Golder
who didn't want to hurt anyone and it is
best to stop the holy war and we see
some other demons who start off as
ruthless like derriere iman speed and
fraud Rijn
actually change and learn to care about
other creatures including humans as the
story goes on so this isn't a story
about clear-cut good guys and bad guys
despite being a fantasy this is a story
that includes realistic characters and
realistic relationships there are some
good people and some bad people in each
clan and there are those who are able to
change and develop as characters once
they get to know more about their
so-called enemies and realize that these
enemies are not all bad and this clearly
reflects the reality of our own world
the extremism and cruelty of the godess
clan and their religious conviction that
all the demons must be exterminated in
many ways references extremists in our
own world from the Spanish conquistadors
who forced the natives of South America
to convert to Christianity or suffer
terrible consequences to the Ottoman
Turks who forced Eastern European
Christians to convert to Islam or
suffered terrible consequences
not to mention the tragic events of the
Salem witch trials where woman were
accused of being witches and then
executed allegedly for their own good
because their executioner's believed
that it was better for them to die than
to live as impure demonic creatures as a
small child I lived through the civil
war in the former Yugoslavia and I
witnessed firsthand how people tend to
act like whichever side they belong to
is always right and the other side is
pure evil and responsible for all the
bad things that happen I am Serbian but
I was never foolish enough to think that
all creations were bad or that all Serbs
were good because of course there are
good people and bad people on all sides
in fact my mom's best friend is Croatian
and because she married a Serbian man
she often faced problems and she ended
up having to move to Serbia from Croatia
because she was constantly criticized
for marrying a Serb and I can relate
this personal experience back to the
seven deadly sins where we clearly see
that there are good people and bad
people in every clan including the
goddesses and the demons and of course
Elizabeth and meliodas are the perfect
example of a mixed marriage to members
of rival clans who end up being cursed
by their own parents and accused of
treason by their clan just because they
fell in love with the wrong person and
this is why I feel that the story of the
seven deadly sins really speaks to me
and why I think that it is a lot deeper
than it first appears as the story
continues in the manga honestly just
keeps getting better and better as we
learn more about the demons the
goddesses and the real truth about the
holy war even though it takes place in a
fantasy world with magical creatures and
legendary weapons the story of the seven
deadly sins has a lot to teach us and
the themes that a tackles are clearly
applicable to our own world this is why
I love this series and why I think that
the manga is better now than it has ever
been and it's also why I keep
recommending to everyone that I know to
read this manga but let me know what you
guys think what do you think about the
way that the conflict between the
goddess and demon clans has been
portrayed in the seven deadly sins do
you believe that there are more
mysteries about the previous holy war
that we are yet to discover maybe
something more linked to the original
goal thir and how do you think that the
story will end
let me know down in the comments I
always love hearing from you if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more content along these lines you can
leave a like to let me know and if you
are new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
you can follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar for all the
latest updates and if you'd like to
support more content like this in the
future you can check out our online
store where we have original anime
inspired merch like this praise the sun
shirt created by pro artist whose o
matic
a big thank you to de la mancha - for
allowing me to use his art in this video
including these colored images of my L
check out his deviant art page and show
some love link in the description as
always thank you all so much for
watching I really appreciate it and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you